we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p and today's
voicemail is once again this nonsense
type of thing about david will you will
you trash sam cedar will you trash some
other host but it's actually kind of a
funny one and it might even be
tongue-in-cheek so let's take a listen
to it
hey david this is uh justin here i just
want to know do you think that sam cedar
is like in the pocket of big business i
mean if you look at his career his
resume he's in a pocket of big you know
sex and city bank cause burgers big
martin aaron like serious think you
think he's a and it can act like
yourself are you doing you too you know
big corporatist and a [ __ ] to these big
corporate media corporations i just
wanted to know your answer on this all
right have a nice day okay yeah so
listen if that's tongue-in-cheek if
that's satire going back to this entire
thing of Oh tattle on sam cedar tattle
on David Pakman two Sam seed or get this
host to attack that host if it's satire
it's very very clever if it's serious
seek help is my only answer on today's
bonus show we will talk about
congressman Duncan Hunter using campaign
funds for his personal sexual affairs
according to prosecutors we will talk
about San Francisco banning the sales of
e-cigarettes and we will also talk about
some billionaires who have made what to
some people is a surprising request to
the twenty20 Democratic candidates the
billionaires that are saying tax me more
put more taxes on me as a billionaire
because we believe it would be good for
the economy all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show two ways to
get access to the bonus show they both
are instant access and take under a
minute okay number one become a member
at WWN pakman.com number two become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show look forward to talking to you on
the bonus show today